[Music]
in a long time new submitted by wax on
wax off
a woman was challenged to spend five
days in solitary confinement trouble
starts after 72 Jane you know it should
be 100% with you I think I'd be okay in
solitary confinement not all the time
though but at least 72 hours do I get to
go online
no you just by yourself by your own
thoughts that's boring no Wi-Fi there
like as a punishment it's a punishment
or she chose to do a challenge a
challenge what is this part of a TV show
actually so this is on Channel Five's
and it's solitary TV shows like those
sense deprivation no it's like a room
that they have it looks like solitary
confinement in prison right I think I
saw that like the shoe right the Colin
showed us to be cool
they caught the shoe I think right I
think so it's like cool sign for it
yeah I like I take it back I can't do it
what I just started picturing it yeah
and I freaked out and I just think I
just freaked out yeah I don't need
internet it's just like because I think
like beyond just knowing that you're
because I was need something like I need
a pencil
yes damn well just give me a [ __ ]
back way yeah if I had like one activity
yeah I can be alone for a long time if I
had the internet that would be awesome
people not alone you're not really alone
than their internet I know I agree
that's I'm saying if I was in the same
room
and the same circumstances for the same
amount of time people bring you [ __ ]
food to your door it's a gross no you
can't have any social interactions no
internet no phone full the day they just
like kick a tray of food under your door
I'm not sure if I prefer that then right
now where I have to like see the GrubHub
guy the door it's like a weird person
like honestly in my head it's like jail
when they slide it under your freaking
Jail that's better I wish GrubHub did
that [ __ ] if you could draw like faces
on the wall you could have conversations
with the faces I used to do that when I
was a kid a lot really me to draw faces
on the wall I used to like have
different voices and like talk to myself
in the different voices and like have
conversations because it was like having
friends you're meant to be a play writer
I start to get creeped out by the old
you more and more as it
the old you warm packs I really I didn't
do that but I feel like I probably told
were some loser probably hello no talk
with my mouth closed that way this was a
lot of time no she's good at it she's
actually really good at it how have you
had a brother
so you could be a really good
ventriloquist yeah it's really good I'll
be like hey Nikki how's it going fine I
guess were you not allowed to go out you
shouldn't be long I was at a
babysitter's house all day and they
didn't hang out with you what in the
[ __ ] is so it was just Todd about this
and me I got 8 years old like I was like
8 and they were all like couldn't speak
English yet they were toddlers I'm so
glad my mom didn't know how dangerous
the world was cuz she just let me
[ __ ] out yeah they don't matter she
says when the Sun comes down that's your
cue to come home we're getting a [ __ ]
ass whoopin yeah but you don't have cool
voices that you could talk to see with
your mouth closed are you ready rest of
this episode we're all in our mouths go
low leanness yeah so I could do solitary
confinement really a skill fine I have a
skill too I can stab myself in the chest
multiple times ex a survival skill you
kind of like have to fit the words with
ends like net wood and that's like
please say [ __ ] you like Kyle's brother
in South Park I think we're all afraid
of is that this is her real talent
that's the epitome of your talent that's
it that's no I can also touch my foot to
my head so I see I thought you were
gonna say like you were like a
ventriloquist and I was super excited
and then you did that so I got
disappointed
dubidouxs of course have the doll in the
lap and their cheeks like no because
then they could be great yeah exactly
I can't throw my voice mm-hmm
you know I can't G this is why I love
her she's the weirdest person in the
world by collecting all these things
about you and it's just like what the
[ __ ] is going on dude no there's baby in
my childhood where I'm on like a fake
imaginary phone like and like all the
other kids are playing right here and
I'm like on a fake phone like having a
real conversation that's why but she's
had a bad rap on YouTube because
everyone thought she was a [ __ ] your
own [ __ ]
oh is it possible for her to be [ __ ]
lady they're like yeah right yeah right
exactly
go suck some dick lady's cat she lives
it the stuff that you should let people
know about that be like it was
impossible for you to be a [ __ ] cuz
nobody want to approach you exactly this
nikki 2.0 only happened recently
yeah it's true yeah it was like within
the past ten years
yes that's tight Oh some people would be
like what are you gonna do when your
looks fade and you can't comply oh not
anymore like I never had that do I have
it now like this is very new it can you
please be a mirror for me okay so
there's this woman that she joined this
challenge right for this TV show she did
it with total of five people they're
reporting here that after 72 hours alone
she started hallucinating and talking
herself and weird [ __ ] I do that the
first hour I wake up are you a pep-talk
kind of guy in the morning
look come on Joe we can do a baby cuz
that's the Troublesome activities just
talking she would see things in a sink
that weren't there and because they gave
her a camera and so I'm gonna show you
guys well she got a sink are you allowed
to use the bathroom I will show you a
clip you'll see where's my prison cell
doctor Pauline is concerned for Sara's
safety and the production
team is considering removing her from
the experiment I'm doing the robot
she just looks like everyone in LA like
on the street in fact she looks like a
blogger I don't know what she's gonna
what is she meditating what does she see
a spider no she would hear like things
and then it would freak her out okay you
know what I think she already crazy I
feel like that one place I could sleep
all day I took it back I took it back
100% I could do that for 72 hours
because what I was picturing was just a
blank white wall room and then me
sitting down in a tray and then a toilet
in the corner that's a room I could do
that well that's it's five days as the
challenge she couldn't she went crates
she couldn't last 70 I was thinking that
it would just be 72 hours oh I could
just have you to it I couldn't do this
[ __ ] I have to be around people doing
they're just saying that after 72 hours
that's what she started kind of losing
it a little bit I mean this is just
depression true like a week whatever but
that's easy
yeah I was thinking the same thing I'm
like I feel like I could totally do this
yeah so the reason why I actually joined
this challenge is because she's a single
mother of an eight year old and she just
wanted some alone time and she also
wanted to test to see how strong of a
person she really is to even go through
something like this did it win anything
I wanted to know that - they don't
really talk about a prize but it's just
to see if you can get through it out of
the five people she was only one of
three that was able to do it so it's the
two other people they've dropped out one
girl she dropped out after like four
hours the other person who is the host
of the show dropped out after 23 hours
that's always gonna say I feel like a
lot of people today they have an escape
TV iPhone whatever so they're not
comfortable in their own mind what would
probably get me is the closed space I
could do the island if I if I have
survival skills put me there yeah if you
have nature yeah you play with bugs you
know I got my Wilson yeah you can
observe things maybe the lack of
sunlight money
- and you can't observe anything when
you're like there's no looking out on
the trees or the ocean it's just blank
walls that'll drive me crazy
have you tried the sensory DEP right now
I would do this year I've done it twice
and both times I'm like a little yeah I
think I would freak out a little bit
with that would forget to be in water
you're in water and they're in the
closed space like honestly that's okay
heavily like solid an open space the
second time so that was a lot better but
I still couldn't do it being in complete
darkness yeah that's the thing that kind
of freaked me the first time I did it I
couldn't even like be still without some
noise so I had to keep doing this with
my fingers to make the water like
ripples why do you feel scared I guess I
don't know like my mind started playing
tricks on me I kept like telling myself
I just picture that you're in space
floating cool and then all of a sudden
my mind is like there's an alien behind
you you're the luckiest person in the
world if there's an alien behind you by
the way yeah you don't you know see you
know I blackout blinds so like I'm in my
room I can't see [ __ ] really you
probably can't do ayahuasca we live we
leave a light on in our balcony because
I don't like cold I like getting woken
up by the natural light we do Nicky's
pants have a guest room where we stand
and yeah it's [ __ ] nuts keeps your
hands from your faces this close to your
face yeah that's how that's how my room
is at night I can't see [ __ ] and the
reason why is because I get distracted
that's why I have no electronics in my
room
aside from that's good French way I
might like foam radio [ __ ] just like I
set my alarm other than that like unless
is JK news I'll have my phone in there
because if I have my phone I'll be
distracted on that really cuz I'll work
I'll start writing stuff and just like
this all night yeah he's looking at food
recipes or some [ __ ] but he doesn't
even come to bed he just like sleeps out
in the living room while he's on this
boat on computer and stuff oh when you
go down that rabbit hole of research all
this game over dude why they always
watching animals [ __ ] all night yeah
and at the moment it's the most
important thing in the world - it's like
you're like coming up with this crazy a
pivot in the forefront of your thing
mine's always wet nd I always convinced
myself I have some disease or like
infection or something if I cut my
finger I'm like it's I'm dying for sure
I'm dying dude if anything happens if
she drops a [ __ ] Cup or something
like she's basically like I'm
hemorrhaging blood she's like get me to
the freaking hospital you don't even
care
and I'm like you're high you're fine I
mean you're really thought you married
yeah she's the best I mean it's just
it's just you know she's a hypochondriac
she's the best for you I feel like are
all girls hypochondriacs I used to be
worse I'm better now yeah you were worse
I was worse I've had trick disease the
trick disease like they're like
prankster diseases we got like mimic
other like more serious things like
clique who like symptoms no no like I
had I broke out in this like crazy like
rash it looked like a bunch of bug bites
like and they were like ring shaped and
I went to the doctor and he's like you
either have scabies or you have this
like other things this thing called
pityriasis but you're not a pirate so no
so then it was like either my boyfriend
cheated on me and I have an STD yeah or
I have some really benign thing and it
was the benign thing and then one time I
thought I had a heart attack
because it like all the symptoms matched
up to heart attack and you really can't
tell if you were having a heart attack
or this other thing unless you got
hooked up to that like heart monitoring
system thing and so I had to go to the
emergency room and like they had to get
naked in front of like doctor like they
haven't shut me down and like link me up
to this thing to find out that I had
this other thing called Hosbrook oh yeah
so scary
it's just like a rib tendon thing like
your rib tent yes I feel like it comes
Babs your heart a little bit no it feels
like pressure like like exactly like a
heart attack symptoms I don't know I
don't get none of that [ __ ] I hope you
guys enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]
[Applause]